imagine commuting to work at 225 miles
per hour non-stop keep an open mind and
imagine traveling not just a speed but
in comfort this is how one British
designer envisages high-speed rail of
the future utopia for the business
commuter if there is such a thing
perhaps the reality though will prove a
little more mundane fewer sofas maybe
there's better lighting better sound
insulation and more you know amenities
so plugging in your laptop charging
screens to really compete and and get
better than the car alternative the
present reality though is well this a
645 early morning train from London
Euston to burning new Street today but
it's not all about comfort
no more speed and extra capacity are
just the starting arguments they will be
the results of a multi-billion pound
project that the government says hopes
will create jobs and economic growth
I'll actually determined to do what I
can to make sure that British companies
can really prosper whatever contract
they're bidding for over the coming
months and years they need to do that on
a level playing field of course
as he determined to make sure that we
see companies past of this road package
going forward and they're the
government's as a whole the whole line
will run in a y-shaped from London then
up to Manchester Liverpool and Leeds
the government says the project will
cost thirty two point seven billion
pounds overall with 17 billion initially
spent on that London to Birmingham
stretch but one think-tank has done its
sums and doesn't quite agree the
Institute for Economic Affairs
calculates that it will actually end up
costing some forty four point three
billion pounds overall compensation will
have to be paid and upgrading Euston
station will be expensive this will be a
hugely expensive project and most of the
burden of that schedule put onto
taxpayers so it's actually going to be
economic damage to taxpayers and they
will have wider effects for the economy
back on the Birmingham to London line
these are the very business men and
women that this project is supposed to
benefit I think we're probably one of
the last countries to to make this
investment my fear is if we don't make
this investment net investment now and
no changes are made we're going to have
the same problems in ten years time the
major factor about whether reviews hs2
with the dependence on the cost because
it's already expensive to use this there
is an element to this of keeping up with
the Joneses not falling behind
international competitors particularly
for British importers and exporters of
which this company is one when on
building precision equipment as we are
here that it's a requirement for the
customer to come and visit faster
machines up and that sort of thing so we
need high speed rail from London to
Birmingham and we needed to go to the
northeast northwest and eventually
Scotland imagining the future of rail
travel is one thing it opens up all
sorts of possibilities within financial
reason of the course but predicting the
way business will operate in the future
well that's not so easy
think of teleconferencing and faster
broadband when we need to actually
physically travel so much in
thirty years time perhaps not then what
Alistair bundle Sky News central London